j'accueille sawan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu te rends compte si tu te rends compte
de l'effectif de l'effectuer leur fait
passer ses moissons l'événement c'est
les deux enfin les vêtements il n'a pas
beaucoup hein
donc on n'y a pas beaucoup de vêtements
je pense que c'est plutôt toi tu
d'aiguiller les tatouages cacher non
j'ai pataterie pas rien de fait juste ce
tissu très joli très joli c'est à moi
qui est vraiment bon c'est bien c'est
que c'est pas un fou c'est un vrai temps
c'est vrai mais sur le toucher si je
pensais tu finiras c'est dans la très
chic banlieue parisienne de rambouillet
que tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
à wright
l'ancienne actrice porno nous emmène
directement dans une chambre celle de
ses enfants qui fait également office de
bureau
c'est d'ici que zara anime ces quatre
blog j'en aurai qui parle qui s'appelle
la vie de phoenix où je parle des sdf
qui parlent plus qu'ils plus personnelle
mais qui parle toujours de végétarisme
des animaux et les trucs drôles de
politique comme tout ce qui me passe par
la tête
y'en a un autre qui s'appelle arrêter de
monter toujours mais même dans lesquels
je déclare que dans les médias
côté politique on voit toujours les
mêmes têtes quand elle quitte son écran
sarah aime prendre l'air en compagnie de
son chien shiva direction le parc voisin
ici presque incognito elle se fait
appeler esther spencer et a choisi de
vivre près de la nature
[Musique]
inquiet sur paris et tu as la vie métro
les bus et le stress de la ville de les
gens font la gueule qui arrive et si tu
vois ça mais c'est bien mais c'est à
paris questerre est attendue cet
après-midi avant le départ derniers
conseils d'une mère à son fils adoré à
paris
les nouveaux bureaux d'esther se trouve
près de la gare de lyon
voilà mon lieu de travail l'actrice
porno s'est reconvertie en femme
politique elle embrasse désormais les
idées de l'alliance écologiste
indépendante
[Musique]
bon l'antenne locale ne déborde pas
d'activité mais on y retrouve jean marc
le coprésident du parti
quant à esther elle tient le poste de
secrétaire national je vais rencontrer
en 2007 quand j'avais commencé à avoir
l'idée d'utiliser mon nom d'artiste qui
ne me servait à moi absolument à rien et
coup de chance je sais plus pourquoi
mais jean marc qui m'appellent pour une
raison qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec le
politique fauvet que la dynamique était
exactement ce que j'aimais le fait
d'être une idée droite ni la rue ni de
la gauche
oui contre eux enfin continué ferment
en dhr en tout ça m'a parlé beaucoup et
beaucoup esther profite de sa pause
déjeuner pour faire quelques courses au
marché carottes bio évidemment et ce
n'est pas encore pour saisie dès qu'on
la reconnaît dorénavant esther ne rêve
plus de cuir comme autant de ses films
mais de bio moi c'est mon resto
végétarien préféré quelqu'un que j'ai
sont vraiment très honnête et pour moi
c'est un moment
réalité première pour se présenter dans
ce genre de mouvement
en aragon à nice donc qu'on est à côté
de la gare de lyon ce soir il ya congrès
les valises sont faites
esther la pro du porno rêve de devenir
une politicienne de chaque verra bien
mais son plateau de tout le monde a
parlé merci à vous êtes né le 8 novembre
1968 à rotterdam aux pays-bas sous le
nom de esther kullman qu emma goldman
ça fait un peu bizarre alors votre père
était vendeur des espaces publicitaires
dans les magazines
votre mère commence par élevé quatre
enfants ensuite et les serveuses et elle
monte une agence de charme
tiens vous dites il faut comprendre que
dans mon pays le sexe est un business
comme un autre
oui ben en fait en hollande du travail
des sexes on trouve même même dans les
agences intérim dirais que c'est un
travail quoi alors dans les années 70
vous êtes une petite fille qui rêve de
strass et de paillettes
vous vous imaginez sur grand écran en
technicolor avec la vie autour de vous
et tassez et tassez grise imagina à
rotterdam
bah oui j'habite dans un petit village
un petit monde voilà quoi ouais alors
vous fait vos débuts dans le show
business en 1981 il ya une pièce qui est
monté à l'école et vous avez le premier
rôle donc c'est le début oui
ouais c'est quoi cette pièce était une
guide qui a amené les enfants visiter la
france donc avec des chansons en
français tandis qu'on prépare un mot et
un moment j'ai joué le rôle de madame de
pompadour et voilà ouais c'était ça déjà
une prédestination vous êtes vous est
paralysé par le trac mais vous faites
face vous
jouer la pièce quoi déjà extrêmement
volontariste en 1982 c'est le drame
votre père perd son job et le foyer est
déstabilisé qu'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment là quand on perd son job bien sûr
il ya peu d'argent
donc quand il ya plus d'argent la maison
éléphants ou vendus par par la banque je
pense j'étais tellement petit comment je
me suis pas rendu compte a gelé sucrée
après donc ensuite il ya tout les gens
du village qui vient visiter la maison
ouvrir les tiroirs et va donc on est
vite allé vivre dans un autre village où
on a trouvé notre maison et on a
reconstruit à nouveau en 1987 vous
quittez l'école et la maison vous tenter
de vivre en couple avec un amoureux mais
en fait ça se passe pas bien vous
préférez être indépendante quoi oui bah
le mec qui est un peu un peu zarbi aussi
il n'y avait pas vraiment de l'amour
n'avait pas il m'a miné tout le temps
voilà c'était le mec style on inviter
des copains 4 heures du matin il fallait
laver les vitres
parce qu'il y avait des gens qui avaient
fumé lowey a besoin donc je me sentais
très très triste et très seul donc j'ai
préféré vivre
ouais alors vous commencez à cette
époque à poser pour un photographe
on commence à faire des photos un petit
peu sexy et puis c'est vrai que les
hollandais ont une attitude très
décontractée par rapport au sexe oui
c'est un peu comme la gymnastique quoi
faut voir que la hollande
en fait ça ces doubles 1 il ya la partie
très protestant ou absolument le sexe et
pas assez sale c'est un bon truc a pris
alors la hollande très beau tu fais ce
que tu veux tant que tu m'emmerdes mois
voilà alors effectivement cette espèce
de décontraction vous permet de
travailler dans une maison close comme
prostituée dès l'âge de 19 ans en 1988
ça vous pose pas de problème bizarrement
c'était super à l'aise
c'est très bizarre je sais que la
première expérience que j'ai eus je
monte on était avec plusieurs filles
c'est que ça c'est facile et c'est vrai
que votre père vous accompagner en
voiture parce qu'il avait peur que les
chauffeurs de taxi vous sautent dessus
donc vous alliez au bordel accompagné
par papac en fait ce que vous habitez
dans un tout petit village très éloignés
il fallait que je prenne des taxis et le
chauffeur de taxi quand il sait ce qu'on
fait comme métier donc où il va m'amener
il essaye d'en profiter il devient
insultant et mon papa par geste d'amour
parce que je me dis que c'est dû être
difficile
il a dit bon ça va être mon alors quitte
à mais non non je suis sûr que tu
arrives en sécurité fournie est
l'endroit où vous travaillez s'appelle
le white
oui ce qui sera finalement votre nom de
star quoi vraiment de scène voilà alors
en 1989 vous déménagez en italie vous
devenez la maîtresse d'un conte italien
ouais et alors été comment se comptent
les arbitres aussi oui quand on met des
gens sur des arts dits oui c'est pas
juste
en fait ils devaient faire des photos je
faisais un spectacle pour la télé à
milan vous étiez potiche pour la télé on
prend un peu la potiche koala et
et ensuite on avait deux semaines de
tournage et deux semaines de libre donc
pas encore profité travaillé pendant les
deux semaines est libre donc on m'a
envoyé à rome pour faire des photos et
ça se passait dans le château de ce
compte là et que bien sûr quelqu'un qui
est gentil et qui me fait un gros
sourire moi je tombe amoureuse quoi donc
je restais et voilà si tu n'es peut vous
dites je vis sans savoir de quoi demain
sera fait et je m'étonne pas de me
retrouver à los angeles pour un shooting
photo qui va transformer ma vie là vous
commencez à cette époque à los angeles à
tourner des films x vous dites j'étais
payé pour vivre mes fantasmes
ben oui parce que bon j'avais 19 ans et
il y avait plein de trucs qu'on n'ose
pas faire mais sous le
la couverture que c'était pas moi mais
le rôle qu'ils jouent et ses fontaines
et là j'ai découvert un peu ma propre
sexualité à travers ça je n'ai jamais
fait ce que je voulais pas faire donc je
choisissais mes partenaires mais mes
positions un machin je gagnais bien ma
vie je m'éclate et quoi j'étais folle je
vais m'amuser comme une folle ouais
ouais
cette page tu es jeune ouais alors là
entre 1990 et 1992
vous allez tourner 27 films qui vont
vous rendre mondialement célèbre parce
que votre célébrité elle n'est pas
seulement européenne et américaine
finalement en 54 jours de tournage vous
avez bâtir 20 ans de notoriété quoi
c'est bizarre vas-y combien de gens
aient regardé mais c'est fou ça lui
sinon le truc le plus stupide c'est que
je suis devenu connu moi que j'avais
arrêté parce qu'en fait de ma carrière
était très très court très très bien
même pas deux ans quoi et un moment
j'arrête
et du coup c'était surtout en france
était prête à la télé magellan fille du
x et commencer à avoir un nom oui c'est
comme les tops mannequin c'est vrai mais
c'est pas là on avoue remporté les avait
eus à las vegas le hot d'or à cannes en
92 pour rêve de cuir qui est un film
c'est le meilleur régime beaucoup et
ensuite au d'or d'honneur en 1994 c'est
comme une consécration mais tient bon
vous êtes une star à ce moment là
c'était rapide comme célébrités donc
deux ans de travail il célébrités
éternel benz trucks le plus bizarre et
que je n'ai pas fait pour devenir connus
youtube d'ailleurs je savais même pas
qu'on pouvait devenir connus en et enfin
les films qua non
si je savais pas trop ce qui m'arrivait
ce qui va aussi que j'en suis pas devenu
risque du tout parce que comme j'étais
devenue connue qu'après way est les
plateaux télé ne s'appelait pas donc je
vivais vraiment avec un minimum syndical
mais j'étais content de quoi je
m'amusais quelles ont été les réactions
de votre entourage vous parents par
exemple quand vous avez commencé à être
célèbre au départ quand je commençais
faire des films à hollywood faisait des
films pense pas tout de suite ces gens
ne filme la mets mes parents me
connaissant ils savent qu'en tout cas je
fais ce que je veux donc voilà donc je
les ai fait venir aux états unis pour
voir ce que j'ai fait que c'était un
milieu qui n'est pas comme le milieu
maintenant mais c'est à cette époque là
c'était assez bien quoi et ils ont
accepté
voilà je crois que mes soeurs pendant un
petit moment ils ont mal vécu parce
qu'elle était encore à l'école et j'ai
toujours évité on peut faire des
émissions de télé en lambeaux
quelquefois je suis quand même passé ce
qui fait qu'à l'école pour elle ça a été
un peu dur mais ensuite c'est nos amis
comment ils ont réagi
ce sont mes amis donc vos amis même
comme je suis dit voilà voilà
avec les médias comment ça s'est passé
parce que vous avez été quand même l'une
des actrices les plus médiatisés des
années 90 2000
mais les relations avec les médias et
bien les gens aiment invités et commence
à me ça m'amuse de passer devant un
camara voilà je m'éclate et ça m'a pas
apporté du travail aux hot sauce à
m'apporter notoriété kike enfin compte
me servait pas vraiment quoi mais ça
m'amuse et voilà j'ai jamais eu de
problème avec les médias avec les médias
même nom bon tu peux avoir un
journaliste quand tu fais par exemple
une fois j'avais dit que je confiais
toujours aimé les animaux que je
comptais faire un calendrier avec des
animaux et donc le journaliste a écrit
que dans les faire un truc zoophiles
quoi effectivement il ya des corps
partout même en faire avec c'est pas si
grave ce plan financier vous touchiez
1250 dollars de cachet pour tourner les
films et après les producteurs se sont
fait de l'argent pendant des années avec
ses 1 toujours d'ailleurs
ouais moi non ouais nan on question
amour vous avez rencontré l'amour à
cette époque
souvent on s'est dit c'est l'amour et
puis après ça se finit et c'était et oui
je tombais amoureuse j'ai eu quelques
relations de longtemps quand même donc
oui bien sûr ce n'est pas l'amour comme
je te connais maintenant mais bien sur
wii en fait il faudra attendre 1999 pour
que vous vous mariez vous jamais eu
envie avant c'était contre le mariage en
fait j'avais pas trop les contrats oui
et apparemment là j'étais assez mûr pour
que oui je voulais comme je voulais
aussi des enfants
auparavant je voulais jamais pas non
plus je pense que oui là j'étais venu
pour tous et laudun comment tu laisses à
s'installer
merci c'est ça et votre votre mari le
fait que juillet était une actrice porno
ça le dérangeait pas non non non ce qui
est assez drôle c'est qu'à cette époque
mon mari travaillait dans le basket et
été préparateur physique du psg l'époque
et quand je venais voir les match dans
les vestiaires je sortais déjà avec lui
me disait rien il s'éclate et dans les
desserts mais sinon non non non ça ne va
pas je n'ai aimé moi pour qui je suis
quoi de fait deux enfants avec lui ça
vous a fait du bien à ça change une vie
franchement ça m'a calmé ça m'a apaisé
ça va donner
ça m'a beaucoup fait réfléchir oui vous
avez 1 cuil
quel était le meilleur moment de toute
cette époque ça mais tu sais ce que
j'aimais bien moi c'était quand je
voyage beaucoup et que je voyais des
endroits que d'habitude j'aurais pas
peut-être pas vu et que je pouvais
inviter ou maman papa venir partager ces
moments avec moi j'ai adoré ça ouais
ouais
et le pire moment c'était quoi je pense
que le pire moment c'est la drogue
vous avez pris de la cocaïne beaucoup
par période
oui mais quand on était dedans
après on arrête pas après quoi on s'en
prend juste une ce soir
d'accord les partis moi comme je vois
pas l'alcool avec et voilà quoi non la
durée quand même temps cette époque et
des périodes où je faisais une au moment
donc je pouvais tous les jours et puis à
des périodes où il y avait des grandes
pause qui est d'ailleurs me faisait
beaucoup de bien et j'ai mis un bon bout
de temps et c'est un grand combat pour
l'arrêter parce que on en rêve toujours
si on a peine autre dealer avec un
téléphone john d comment le téléphone
sonne on pense à coquilles dès qu'on
rentre en telle personne a avec lui je
les fais et l'envié revient donc si ça a
été un long combat est encore des nuits
où j'en rêve
je me frapper mais et xavier l'argent
pour acheter ça bien il ya toujours des
potes qui offrent c'est facile à offrir
à une fille parce qu'après on pense
pouvoir faire quelque chose mais moi ça
me rend complètement président c'est
carrément un nouveau régime c'est demain
sur les jeunes qui payent aujourd'hui
vous êtes nostalgique de cette époque
au lieu où les films x ce que je
regrette je pense que c'est que ça m'a
ouvert certaines portes mais ça en a
fermé plein d'autres parce que comme en
france surtout en france on a un mix
tatouille for love poule sur le front et
j'ai tellement aussi j'ai tellement
envie de faire des émissions télé sur
l'écologie se dé tout ludique et
émergents et quelque part cette image ne
m'empêche de le faire quoi mais regretté
tout ça non je me suis amusé c'est une
page qui est tournée on commence un
autre tous les jours vous avez de la
rancune contre certaines personnes de
l'époque j'aurais pu en avoir
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui m'ont
fait beaucoup de mal et avec du recul on
se dit ça m'a énormément aidé à évoluer
à travailler sur moi donc maintenant
c'est perçu même personnage et dit merci
qui vous a fait du mal
j'ai un manager par exemple et qui m'a
pas vraiment posé de gros problèmes avec
l'état qui est qui m'a complètement
arnaquer qui
et voilà quoi plus que
l'aspect financier c'était pour moi
c'était mon deuxième père était un
trahison qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup
blessé mais ça m'a fait grandir
énormément aussi tout ce qui ne vous tue
pas vous rend plus fort
bravo c'est complètement ça c'est
nietzsche c'est pas de moi alors si
c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne
referiez pas pareil faire trop vite
confiance aux gens ouais
les champions de la carrière fort hier
la même chose il ya le weitz au départ
les films x
je ne peux pas m'imaginer ne pas alors
l'avoir fait parce que s'il n'aurait pas
fait je serais pas ici aujourd'hui dans
la cèze avec toi tu es déjà donc comme
là je suis bien
oui oui je regrette pas ça non et le
jour vous allez mourir qu'est ce que
voulait qu'on écrit que sur vos tombes a
dit my way
tiens c'est très bien merci sarahc très
heureux de rallumer la lumière sur vos
ça c'est beaucoup
merci à toi et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou